the story we were looking at is from CNN
student loan interest resumes Friday and
payments restart in October here's what
borrowers should know for the first time
in more than three years federal student
loan borrows borrowers will be required
to pay their monthly student loan Bills
starting in October the pandemic related
pause which went to effect March 2020
provided relief to nearly 44 million
borrowers by freezing their accounts
interest will start accruing again on
September 1st after rates were
effectively set to zero uh since March
2020 we know that now interest rates
which are fixed and vary by loan will
return to the same rate they were before
the freeze but borrowers still won't
need to take any action until their
first monthly payment is due which means
if you don't take action you will be
accruing interest on your debt and then
have to pay more money and for most as
an aside the difference between a
forbearance and a deferment is that a
forbearance means you don't have to pay
but you're still accruing interest
whereas a deferment you don't pay but
you don't accrue interest and those are
ideal you know if you're going to put
them off for most borrowers the first
payment will be due sometime in October
but not everyone has the same date the
exact same date borrowers can expect to
receive their bill listing their payment
around the due date at least 21 days
beforehand so uh this will my payments
be the same they generally will be how
do I find out blah blah blah my payments
were automatic before but these
questions aren't really as relevant what
happens if I don't pay my student loan
bill because interest will start
accruing on September 1st not making a
payment will result in a borrower owing
more on their student loans over time
but for the next year through September
30 2024 the government is providing what
is calling an on-ramp period during
which borrowers are shielded from other
normal consequences of missing a payment
a loan servicer for uh won't for example
report the loan is being in default to
the national credit rating agencies
borrowers don't need to apply for this
benefit
this is one of the funnier elements of
this it means that as the economy starts
crumbling and debt spirals out of
control you won't be able to know about
it because they're not going to report
the delinquencies that means when that
on-ramp period ends you're going to see
delinquencies from like three percent to
like 43 overnight
I wonder if we get to a point just like
we were just talking about with laws
where people like I don't I don't
respect that law people are just like I
don't respect my debt I think there are
a lot of people who say stuff like that
like why this is like I'm never gonna be
able to play this off I'm not going to
deal with it like there's nothing I can
do I mean ultimately theoretically with
consequences but this is why the
argument of like Joe Biden campaigned on
I am going to forgive student loans that
was him saying essentially I'm gonna
bail you guys out and that's what people
why people feel attached to him I think
and why it's potentially the biggest
flaw in his campaign because there are
people who need are counting on the fact
that they will not have to pay these
loans because they see it as an
impossible Financial hurdle I was gonna
say the the biggest problem for me is
that there's no
um there's nothing stopping it from
happening again if they were to bail
everybody out right because once they
stopped issuing government-backed
student loans which they won't do they
still haven't done it sorry well even on
top of that they're not doing anything
as far as the universities what's their
culpability to it like why why does the
same school that that taught your
parents how can they cost 10 times more
no no one addresses that but they can
just charge whatever they want and the
government just packs it up how come the
government doesn't have stipulations
right why can't you default on student
loans right why can't we do well then
yeah you used to be able to I think
George Bush Jr made it illegal to
bankrupt your student loans 2003 or
something right because and I'm willing
to bet I could be wrong it's because the
federal government stepped up
even more with student loans so they
said if we're going to step up even more
and invest in the American public we
can't have them all defaulting because
that would default the government well
here we are
rather than just be like maybe this
isn't a great system maybe we should
consider not issuing these maybe we
shouldn't be so obsessed with college
being the one path to anywhere in
America oh I'm sorry I get the banks are
for profit so they want to charge you
interest to make money which is
disgusting but that's the system but
that the government is doing this
for-profit that they're going to loan me
money and then expect interest back like
they loan me 20 grand I don't want to
pay them back more than 20 grand I've
already paid 13 000 in interest but
that's it's not so much about a profit
it's about how the modern monetary
system works and with the creation of
the money supply what they want you to
do is pay back uh Grant don't get me
wrong like a lot of these interest rates
are greater than greater than the rate
of inflation but a component of it is if
uh the economy is inflating by three
percent we want you to pay back
comparable buying power if we give you a
hundred apples we want 100 apples back
guess what in a year apples are going to
cost more money you're gonna need more
money to pay back I would I'd be down
with that if they if they if you pay
back with a your increase with inflation
if it went up with inflation that would
be understandable that would be
logistical but this just flat out
interest rates compound interest on 18
year olds that don't aren't taught about
compound interest full predatory man and
I I don't refuse to pay back the
interest I'm not interested in doing it
here's the story from entrepreneur.com
this gets worse before it gets better
Kevin O'Leary warns of real chaos set to
hit the U.S economy this fall
but this was interesting I saw this a
couple uh days ago he said you're
starting to see the chips fall the
layering is as follow the regional Banks
don't know yet what their Capital
requirements are going to be so their
loan books are have closed like a turtle
in a shell this gets worse before it
gets better and what's it doing to small
business killing them right now O'Leary
argued that enough money is being pumped
into small businesses and blame most
recent fed hikes including a benchmark
raise of 0.25 last month the only thing
I really care about this article is it's
another high profile business person
sounding the alarm bells in the economy
and after learning about what's about to
happen with student loans kicking in and
a lot of people not being able to pay
them back it is not unreasonable in my
opinion that that could be a large
Catalyst or at least a small component
of I don't know if it's be the big
component of the small component of some
kind of economic crisis especially if it
hits the the co-signers on the student
on the student loan debt and then of
course you have I've mentioned several
times Michael burry betting against the
U.S stock market
it seems like the people who have a lot
of money
are concerned the Market's going to take
a hit I have no idea what that means I
got people asking me every day like
should I buy property right now I'm like
I had no idea because they're like but
if the Market's going to crash I'm like
maybe probably I have no I have no idea
what upsets me the most and so
infuriating is we get these jobs numbers
out every month and the White House or
mainstream media take your pick they put
this positive little spin on it and wrap
it up in a little bow rather than just
telling the Americans hey here's the
problem and here's what you guys can do
as citizens of this country to help
everybody and work towards resolving
this problem because it is so complex
and there's no easy solution out of this
the economy yeah yes I mean this all
ties into the state of the economy right
now it's not monetary that's for sure
we're not going to fix the economy by by
another kind of money it's going to be
through materials I talked with Stu
Peters about this I believe it's live on
his uh channel on Rumble but I'll be
posting a link on that and Twitter later
uh the interview I did with Stu Peters
it's it's technology if we can make
energy cheaper make fuel cheaper then
the economy has become better and so if
you make if a tenth of the economy is
fuel and you make that a tenth cheaper
you basically
made one percent of your economy you've
made your economy a one percent better
you know so it's like
that's why I'm obsessed with hydrogen
fuel right now like I feel like we can
make cheap fuel make cheap heat
electricity building materials
transportation you know the basics you
know you know the trouble is
is when you see these videos at a Time
Square where someone goes up to another
person and says name a country that
starts with the letter U and they can't
do it or they say like who's the current
president of the United States and they
can't they don't know it and they'll say
like when did America get its
independence and they'll be like 1871
like they've no idea
and you have a lot of these people they
vote and when you see these videos there
are powerful individuals who then are
deeply offended that these people are
consuming resources and polluting and so
they turn around and say stuff like we
need to get a control on overpopulation
because there's too many of these people
weighing us down you then get phrases
like useless eaters you get weird
International policies such as you will
own nothing and you will be happy and
ultimately that means Ian you will not
get your cold fusion and your spaceships
because in the event that there's an
energy Revolution on par with like this
level of Fusion Energy which is insane
that would mean a massive and explosive
population boom that's for sure and
there's a lot of powerful people who
don't want that to happen
you think with how expensive college is
we'd be seeing some more of this uh
these technological advancements we
wouldn't be seeing train derailments in
East Palestine with how much Americans
are paying for college but we're not
we're not because like college is a is a
business right like I don't even know
that all degrees are equal and I think
there are programs that are probably
great but generally people are paying to
have their certificate they are not
actually always advancing to the level
that we'd like to see or that would be
implied by the fact that you went to
college a lot of people are in debt
basically having graduated by the skin
of their teeth and Having learned
nothing I mean there are colleges that
close during covet because the
enrollment is so low and because
ultimately the business of college is
failing you know you know small rabbit
monkey said yes you Willy and don't
listen to Tim
no I think we will but think there's
powerful individuals who are trying to
reduce population and they have a they
have a reasonable fear because if every
human had access to unlimited energy
Timothy McVeigh what else would he have
blown up like the a psycho-terrorist
that had a horrible childhood just beat
that hates Humanity has access to
unlimited power like that's severely
dangerous so I understand why but
there's scales I don't want to give
everyone cold fusion packs just yet but
hydrogen fuel it's lightweight and could
be cheaper than gasoline I I'm thinking
about what is about to hit the economy
and perhaps the only solution is going
to be student loan debt forgiveness in
some capacity it was easy to say when we
were talking about 24 and 25 year olds
up to maybe like early 30s that we don't
want to forgive student loans these
older people have all paid them back
it's like look these people hate the why
it's not fair there's a lot of questions
about fairness about making the working
class pay the bills of the highest
income earners
but I think there is a a harsh reality
to
whatever your opinion is you're
presented with two
parent factions or parent paths to take
one we do not bail out the people who
have student loan debt and then these
people who are in their mid late 30s and
40s don't have families don't have kids
don't buy property become angry and
purposeless and and violent
or we do bail them out and the people
who are supposed to be the Crux of the
economy
resume working have the load taken off
their backs and it stabilizes things a
little bit
it's a question about the 2008 crisis
when they bailed out the banks do you
let the economy just course correct
shock everybody there is going to be
large amounts of death because of this
because of the economic crisis or do you
bail out alleviate some of the crisis
extend it for a little longer but reduce
the amount of death it's serious
questions I think that the the
reasonable approach that the government
will likely want to take is going to be
a bailout whether Joe Biden wants to or
not and in fact you may see this in 2024
Joe Biden coming out and saying one of
the biggest drags on our economy right
now is student loan debt and you all
know it each and every one of you that
has settled the debt that you can't pay
back as you're living paycheck to
paycheck we will get it done we will
pass the pass the Bill blah blah blah
you gotta vote for Democrat down ticket
what's Trump going to say
well you look at what they're doing so
if I owe Joe Biden 10 grand in debt he's
like you can't pay that back so what I'm
going to do is print money and then take
it from you and pay me back sooner right
I'm like dude you can't force me to pay
you back Joe Biden and you so no
no let me pay you back at my Pace I
think which is not which is a zero
because I have no interest in paying it
back but I think the libertarian
response is going to be let the system
crumble just let it fall apart and then
we'll just restart from where we're all
about with putting the the default on
the loaners whoever loaned the money
you're not getting it back I'm not all
about printing up money to pay back
those loaners but the problem is the
loaner is the government so they got to
take the default I mean what's the point
anyway it's like a trillion bucks what's
the difference I mean I would love to
have one presidential candidate say when
I'm in office I'm going to stop issuing
student loans right because the system
is broken we can see it we haven't dealt
with the Fallout yet but no one is
saying that like why can't we just stop
a terrible program from existing I gotta
I gotta read this super chat from sunny
summer Summoner uh what's it say Sumner
Robinson Citibank has a total of is that
uh 14 trillion no 14 billion 15
basically about 15 billion I was like
the trillion doesn't mean oh no no okay
I see right here 15 billion shorting the
NASDAQ and the 7 billion showing the s p
Bank of America has 23 is that billion
shorting the NASDAQ and 18 billion
shorting the s p
reminds me of The Big Short when uh the
guys who bet against that the housing
market were wondering why their credit
default swaps were stable as
delinquencies were skyrocketing and the
mortgages were becoming worthless it's
because the banks were lying about what
was going on so they could offload their
exposure to unsuspecting smaller Banks
and and lenders or individuals so they
would go and say hey this is worth a lot
of money you should buy it then they
would then as soon as they offloaded all
their debt they went markets exploding
have a nice day and nobody goes to jail
for it and uh at the end of The Big
Short remember they they said they've
had a little joke oh we totally held
people accountable just kidding no we
didn't so my question to you guys is
regarding the current situation the
current economy and student loans should
anyone be arrested and if so who should
people be held accountable what should
happen I know you guys kind of started
talking about with the defaulters or or
I don't know about arrest but what I
will say is if you actually want to
solve a problem you first you identify
what's causing the problem
and I don't see that part I see people
are going straight to the problem and
trying to Band-Aid it but ultimately
they're not stopping you know the
bleeding from the wound the the biggest
issue that I see is that the federal
government is trying to play uh
manufacturing middle class
right so that's why they're they're
throwing all this money anybody can get
a student loan that's when you start
seeing for-profit colleges that don't
care about anything whereas our parents
days they got accepted into school that
was the only way you got a college
education right so they had some sort of
Merit base and then on top of that they
had to find some sort of way to get a
loan but back then it was reasonable now
it's become an entire economy on its own
based off of cheap money from the
government but with because it's no
regard they'll just give it to anybody
that's part of the problem same thing
with the 2008 crash ultimately it
stemmed from the federal government
trying to manufacture uh the middle
class by saying the American dream is to
own a home so we're going to make it
easier for everybody and what do they do
they messed up the market and they they
incentivized chaos and that's what we're
seeing with the student loan market and
they're not going to punish the people
who are actually Abu using it right the
colleges no one's talking about the
colleges everything's about what's Joe
Biden going to do no one's ever talked
about the colleges no one ever talks
about the endowment right no one else
what is the endowment what's the
endowment yeah I hear that sees the
endowments what is the endowment exactly
it's basically how much money they just
got sitting in reserves right so even
just money that's been left to them or
given to them yeah okay tax-free stuff
people are donating people are donating
getting a tax credit and then that
generates money off of it does the
government give them endowment money as
well I don't I don't believe so okay I
don't believe so but even even from the
fact that let's say you have a college
that has
um you know 500 million dollars I don't
know I'm just making up a number but
they're still charging your kid twenty
thousand dollars a semester right does
that seem like it makes a whole lot of
sense why is it so expensive not saying
it should be free but why is it so
expensive and on top of that you know I
was talking to Shane Cashman he was an
Adjunct professor they don't pay any
anything for these people and they hire
a whole bunch of adjunct professors so
I'm I mean they're it's a scam it's one
big scam and now they're saying let's
bail out everybody keep the system in
place and guess what in 10 to 15 years
we'll be back at the same point yeah it
seems like the college system is
decrepit at this point and that you can
educate yourself online and learn faster
more readily and from home but are the
salaries of the presidents of College's
public generally speaking I don't know
off the top of my head I think so I'm
curious to see how much money upper
management is making at these schools
because I had no idea about the adjunct
professor Thing 2 million BC yeah that
uh president of Yale makes 1.9 million a
year and remember there's like the
adjunct professors but then they hire
crazy administrative blow right there
was a administrator and a
sub-administrator and someone who helps
with the paperwork and whatever else all
the way down so if the point of the
institution is to have you know
professors that are researching and
studying things that they're good
Educators why are they not the priority
why do we have 85 administrators for
everyone professor that's not the actual
statistic I'm making that up but they're
never they're never incentivized to cut
the fat yeah right there they operate
very soon with how the government
operates they create a job and that job
never goes away right so so if the
government said we will only give money
but only up to a certain amount and they
started doing that wide scale they'd
have no choice but to cut the costs
otherwise they have no customer right so
then what do they do they start cutting
the fat we can't have five
administrators
for for this task we have to reduce it
because we can't afford this if we're
going to keep everybody making about the
same amount so we have to start cutting
the fat no one ever does that when it
comes to college debt they always say
what's the federal government going to
do for us they're the ones who screwed
this all up in the first place and
that's by giving unlimited loans yeah I
mean quite literally
you can't default on it but anybody can
get it were they like trying to catch
catch up with the college's raising
costs so they would give more low they'd
be like oh we'll cover it we'll cover it
I've always heard the inverse that
colleges raise costs because basically
they were guaranteed that you would have
be able to pay tuition instead of being
like well what can the average family or
the average individual reasonably pay to
attend our school they were like well
you just take out a loan right like even
now I don't know if your son will end up
if he's not applied to college yet right
no no okay so some colleges will send
you like the acceptance letter I
remember this happening to me and
they'll be like congratulations you got
a scholarship That's so exciting except
half of your scholarship is a loan so
they're presenting it to you like wow we
want really want you to come here but
actually what they want is for you to
take out a loan to go there which is
what everyone wants you to do anyways
that's also what the federal government
wants you to do one time we talked about
on the show like I don't Advocate that
you give to your University but if you
were to why can't you give directly to a
student who is trying to pay off their
student loans why can't you cover a
portion of tuition instead of it going
into a pool more than the 800
administrators they have decide who gets
it later why can't you have a more
direct contact with the student because
again ultimately a lot of the money goes
into the endowment which never really
reaches the people who need it like the
program heads like the adjunct
professors like the students well back
to what Tim said it's a scam it's not
really about the students right they
give them a superficial product to make
them feel like they're learning right we
go and take these useless classes to
make us feel like we're pro we're being
educated right but they leave and I've
talked to so many college graduates
where I'm like I don't know what I
learned
right so you spent four years in college
you came out learning what but you owe
all this money you got scams son like I
don't know I don't know any other way to
put it what if we had like a patreon
thing for online college I know Jordan
Peterson's working on setting up an
online college and there's like Phoenix
University which was kind of a
predecessor I don't know how that works
exactly but like if you could watch the
individual students learning and you're
like I love that guy I love how fast
he's learning I want to give him 10
bucks a month just like that for a cup
of coffee a day you can but like not the
students the professors oh yeah that's
the professors too that'd be awesome
that's how you do it so what you do is
you create an online university that
gets accredited that issues degrees and
then you say here all the professors and
all the subjects we have available and
when you enroll in one of these classes
you are paying monthly to that Professor
the professor like five percent goes to
the university or 10 like whatever like
by 10 makes sense because there's like
transactional fees and then server fees
but it's basically a patreon for
Education yeah and then when you
complete the course you'll get a degree
from the University but for me who's not
even at the school I just get to watch
them learn online the kids and they
don't have money some of them so I want
to fund them to go to college like I'm
like in my 40s I'm done with that I
just got money lying around I want a fun
I'm just saying I I personally am not in
that state yet but uh there's always
something to do with your money
um but I would like to I would like to
help fund kids without making them take
loans out well those are called
scholarships
yeah so to be like a proactive
scholarship where like you're saying you
can give money like an endowment
directly to the student yeah I wish I
wish there was a scholarship
that isn't administrated by the the
university that's gonna say right
they're private scholarships there's
tons of them yeah where you get to pick
who gets it yeah there's like private
there's not privates and Foundations and
grants and there are foundations that
will be like we give uh a grant to Asian
Americans who are low income and want to
go to college and then they they contact
the institution they fill out paperwork
and they say write us an SNY we should
give you the money and if you get
approved we pay for your account yeah
but I guess I would like to cut out the
middleman where it's like if I had money
I could give it directly to a student at
a school you know what I mean instead of
it going to an administrator at a
non-profit or at a school who then
decides who gets it later build the
technology call it the scholarship it'd
be interesting I I mean one of the the
challenges is that education is great
and I think people feel starved for that
in a way and I wish we had more
decentralized way I mean YouTube is the
great example right everyone always says
you can look up anything on YouTube you
can learn so much and that's amazing I
wish that like it would be cool if
cities had like more I mean public
libraries do this and stuff it's it's
just we default to thinking the
university is what's providing the
lecturers or the the things that you can
go to just to learn and I think that's
where we kind of get this like shopping
mall effect with uh with with
universities we think that's sort of
where you go like after you finish high
school you go there and you get all the
skills you need and then you leave and
it's all kind of centrally located but
really you know if you're actively
interested in a subject you have to be
more proactive the university isn't
going to really educate you on a lot of
things especially we've talked about
this for when you come out of high
school not knowing how to pay your taxes
and things like that like there are
skills that you just continue to put off
and then finally you're like what 20 to
23 getting out of college and maybe you
learn something but also you don't have
any practical skills right and I think I
think part of the problem I think is
Americans have
have caved into thinking that education
is is institutionalized like that's the
only way that you can learn so this
means the only way you can learn is by
going to a public school the only way
that you can have a real education if
you go to a college or university that's
the only way outside of that you're part
of the what non-educated class right
meanwhile these people who spin God
knows how much money you spend how many
years within School come out knowing
nothing
and making less and like it everything
is is the inverse and it doesn't make
any sense I think we are starting to get
back and I'm trying to do this as a
parent to tell my son that intellect is
not necessarily what the teacher
you know puts on your grade intellect is
far more than that
um intellect is about learning on your
own being curious going out in the world
experiencing things having a job dealing
with people right and how you react to
how you react to the world around you in
that way like for example I'm a writer
today I didn't go to school for writing
I figured that out I figured out how to
do all these things by myself no one had
to teach me I just asked questions I
analyze things all that takes intellect
all that takes curiosity but someone
would say I'm not a real writer because
I didn't go to a school to get this to
get disagree I don't need all that I
don't have a college degree at all and
and some people are surprised that by
that because they think that I'm very
intellectual in some regard
credentialism it's credentialism they
think that if you don't have high school
diploma you must be stupid right exactly
and they wonder why they're broke and in
debt and like there's there's the pro
athletes tons of pro athletes especially
in skateboarding easy example tons of
them quit quit High School the GoPro
skateboarding and other millionaires not
all of them but they're the uh college
graduate was it PhD billionaires
typically have less than College Dropout
billionaires thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time